hello everyone this is Amir from audio
science
review uh a couple months ago I uh
published a paper at the audio
engineering Society uh if you don't know
about AES is is the Bible for people in
engineering for both research and uh and
design and uh it's somewhat focused on
professional audio more than consumer
audio but both topics are broadly
covered in there um many of the papers I
site uh for research comes from AES
there are some other organizations too
but this has the most uh impact um
typically I'm not big on writing papers
uh I'm not an acade academic type of
engineer but I thought it was good to
for us uh to spread the message more
broadly than than the the internet to uh
to the uh at least AES and and its
audience and gauge the interest there so
I decided couple months ago to to write
a paper on uh objective uh performance
of Dax in both consumer and professional
uh space uh you can see the title here
um the paper proposal was approved uh I
was appreciative of that and then uh as
uh asked me to um well asks all the
paper presenters to uh uh come to New
York at at the a conference and uh
provide a 10 to 15 minute uh uh version
of of the paper uh there and uh and
that's what I did uh but uh I thought
I'd show you that for the first time uh
we're actually on the map at a so if you
go in there and search for audio science
review you'll find a mention of us there
are actually some other papers that that
reference us also uh which is quite nice
anyway um let's get to the uh
presentation itself uh as I said this is
the title it was a uh the paper is about
uh 10 pages uh very very detailed so
those of you are members or can afford
to pay the $20 or whatever they charge
uh it's worth it to go download that and
you'll see tons of detail about how I
perform de measurements the uh issues
there and so forth and uh while I've
done a video on it and then there's a
text tutorial on the Forum uh this is
much more up to- dat and much more
extensive and authoritative in in the
style that techn papers are published
but uh this version was supposed to be
quite lightweight the presentation and
uh uh sort of the fly through the slides
the uh the 10 pages in in just 10 or 15
minutes so let's get started and some of
this may be known by you those of you
read The Forum probably very much
familiar with this stuff but there's a
bit of detail and some more extra data
that you probably haven't seen it um a
little bit about the history of of of
what I've been doing in um I don't know
how many of you actually know the
history but back in 2017 somebody asked
me to test these $99 dacks to see if
they're any good with understanding that
they're probably not good and uh I
tested one and uh tested three four
other ones and quickly realized there's
a big difference in them so it was uh uh
useful to measure them and and to
distinguish the well engineered ones
from the ones that are not well
engineered and uh for a while I was
buying all the that myself I spent I
think five or $6,000 was getting quite
expensive and I was wondering how I was
going to get to the end of this thing if
I had to keep buying everything that I
tested but then out of the blue somebody
offered me an expensive deck actually I
think it was a mych
and once I reviewed that more and more
people started to uh send me products
and then eventually companies started
sending me products so to this day uh we
have I've tested about probably 450 Dax
and when I said Dax I mean uh uh
Standalone Dax but also Dax inside AV
receivers and professional audio
interfaces and every class really uh
pure Dax is probably a little bit less
than 400 but it's quite substantial and
I don't think people are aware that we
have such a large Li library of of DAC
measurements um the key for me in in
measuring Dax was to present the data in
a way that you could quickly determine
as a buyer whether this is a product
that performs well or average or is poor
performing in that it's a tool for
education of the buyer it is not as a QA
Suite to go test all functionality make
sure everything works like you would run
in a factory or inside a company it was
not run as a academic test to be
published uh you know in a paper it was
designed to convey the performance as
clearly as possible as a result I
minimize the number of measurements
there other people were doing dag tests
before me and a lot of them Fallen by
the wayside because they would just run
scripts generate 400 tests and thinking
the more the better the more is not the
better uh you want to just get in get
out what are the fewest number of tests
you can run to get broad coverage of
performance of a deck and and that's it
no more so over the years people have
asked for more tests and I've gradually
added some but I'm always pushing back
unless there's an absolute clear reason
why we should add a new test I don't
want to add a test they you know with
with two or three tests really you can
tell the story but you know we have more
than that um and uh I didn't realize at
the time but this thing has developed
into a very positive force in the
industry um in that uh you know there's
now objective data that quantifies
performance of products and came at a
time where the industry had basically
abandon all of that even companies are
committed to engineering their spec
sheets really tells you the weight size
of device and how many inputs and
outputs it has and rarely do you get any
specs and if you get any specs with just
a few numbers wouldn't be you know the
extensive sweeps and measurements that I
provide so uh that went really well and
just as a you know side uh note for
which you guys probably aware that you
know that effort started with Dax and
stayed with Dax for a while but now
anything that has audio going in and out
of it I test so it's much broader than
this and I plan to do papers like this
at next year's conference for other
categories probably speakers and maybe
headphones and appli
fars um I talked about how I was uh
looking for a elevator pitch what is the
quick message you can give um to
somebody if they're just impatient or
they don't want to understand everything
without short changing the audience uh
you know I don't want to just again just
give one number uh and uh the analyzer I
use use is from audio Precision their
latest generation and they're the
leaders or number one brand in in this
space and they have a thing called the
bench mode when you go on bench mode it
opens this up as sort of a you know
measurement at a glance and you can
change all of these pains to anything
you want but by default it shows the
scope display as we call this and a 4
year transform of of that same waveform
on the right and U with that we quickly
can see for example the distortion
products here on the right these spikes
are all unwanted the the main tone is at
1 khz here and uh we can actually
perform tack acoustic analysis on on
this on the right and and learn a lot
about the performance of a deck but even
at a glance you can look at and say wow
that's my signal and yeah there
shouldn't be anything here and how loud
are those things you can look at them
over here uh on the left we have the
voltage that is output the test
frequency is 1 khz sort of a little bit
below that that's all right and and then
the number that the industry has used
for decades is tht plus n which is total
arm rank distortions plus noise and is
this number with all these decimal
places and I thought that was just hard
after testing two or three dexs I
couldn't remember the number of zeros in
here whether it was one two or three or
four or five or what these numbers were
it's just not a human readable number
once you go below you know .1% but
fortunately audio Precision has this
simple math it performs on on THD plus n
is that it just converges to a log value
and when he does that he gets a negative
number and if you throw away the
negative number you get what it's called
a sign ad so this sign ad is now a
positive number it's much easier to
remember 123 than this
0069 and uh shortly after that I took
this uh again when I started testing
things I started to forget the sign out
also so for my own sake I started to
make a table uh plotting the sign ad
values and at the time of course there
was only three or four items in there
now this graph has uh you know 400 items
in it and uh quickly I decided that to
take away the focus from the decimal
place and and assign that and say what
are the four buckets and actually got
user input also from the membership on
color coding and everything and we
decided to have these four buckets
lowest bucket is poor the middle bucket
is you know fair and they is to be very
good and excellent and uh so you guys
have seen my sign at chart but you
probably haven't seen these notations
that I put on to for the as Community
that's probably not as familiar with
this and say hey pay attention to some
things uh for example the fourth or
fifth worst one is this PS audio deck
down here uh retails for
$1,600 and if you go all the way out
here there's a deck from smsl is only
$80 think ASU W so you can see what a
messy situation we have and if we had
graphs like this and consumers were
educated nobody in their right mind
would go buy this stag when they can buy
this one for a fractional price and gets
an incredibly better performance uh the
top of the line deck is uh the number
one one that competes just the air with
all the other ones is a $900 smsl deck
again and I think topping is right next
to it um so for less than a thousand you
can get the best there is in here uh I
pointed out that the the best interface
audio interface I've tested uh is this
Apollo one I think it's x16 and it's
$3,500 uh Thunderbolt uh audio interface
and it lands in here so Pro industry is
not where the consumer industry is and
I'll talk about that and at some other
interesting data point I showed how a $9
Apple dongle lands over here just at the
a beginning of very good again compared
to, 1600 PS audio and that if you have a
perfect 16bit audio you land somewhere
in here so you need high resolution
audio to get to past that point with the
24-bit audio samples specifically to get
above the graph but everything below
this point this Arrow here uh actually
can't even meet the CD spec uh it's got
worse Distortion than 40y old
format
okay um from here on I'm just showing
quick snapshots of good uh and really
bad and again these are used in the
paper I'll go through all the details of
them uh here you see sort example of
state-of-the-art uh deck which is a
topping d70 Pro and I show that I
converted these decibel numbers that the
audio Precision just measures it and
other analy they do the same thing again
it's hard to know what what does 129
mean what is what is 100 what is 85 what
what do these things mean so if you just
convert this uh thing to what is called
effective number of bits oops there's a
spelling error should be EOB instead of
ebug up um and they divide this by six
you get effective number of bits and I
do that and says that this dck has an
effective resolution if you will of 21
A2 bits uh research shows that best case
music that's produced has about 18 bits
of dynamic range so 21 bits is more than
we need and and anything over 20 bits
it's just great but it's it incredible
that we have
21.5 bits we have in here in the deck
that's a few hundred and uh this is with
a balanced output and there's unbalanced
output over here a little bit less and
then on the other hand this a tube deck
somebody decided to stick a tube in in
the deck and look at this its effective
number of bits only 12 bits in here so
things can get pretty bad uh uh at the
low end of performance but actually
expensive
stuff uh Jitter I again show the example
of good and bad uh this is again the
same topping deck and not only does have
very low uh noise floor you can actually
see these spikes in here they're
actually part of the signal down to the
rightmost bit of a 24bit sample so it's
incredible that we this able to resolve
this uh on this thing and I explained
that I show all three inputs this is an
example of old deac The Moody one I
think that is very susceptible to a uh
USB Jitter and USB power and uh it
produces pretty horrible input uh
uh pretty horrible Jitter measurements
fortunately they're way past this and
their new products are
excellent um somewhere halfway in the in
the testing I got tired of people
complaining that oh I'll go test just do
one bit comparisons and music is not one
bit so there's standard test uh called
multi-bit that you can take as many uh
tones as you want combine them together
and get one test signal and this
actually tastes like sounds like an
orgon if you listen to it and I started
add this and this was pretty good
actually I realized it actually has good
value in that at a glance you can tell
where inter modulation Distortion is
generated in case of this topping deck
again is beyond approach it's it's just
excellent and has extremely low noise
floor but you can see this other dck in
here that uh you know how much noise it
has and how it can't get below minus 70
DB again I do some kind of the bit
conversion I take this distance from
here to here divided by six and I
describe that this stck has 23 bits of
of uh headro if you will before
Distortion sets in this one is only has
11.7 bits so the good and bad are just
the distance between them is just
amazing um inter modulation Distortion
the previous test actually does this but
in this case uh I use the CT IMD test
which has a six uh uh 60 HZ and 7 khz
tones in there so we're simultaneously
testing for Distortion at a low and a
high frequency tone and here again an
excellent deck uh is way down here I
explain how it's good to have references
many people publish measurements with no
indication to a user of what's good
what's bad here I put in this is a
dongle phone dongle from Razer and I use
that as a Poe reference and this is an
older topping deck and I a very good one
and you can see this dck that I'm
testing is way better than even our very
good reference
and uh a few years ago I noticed that
some of the DXs I was testing had a
regression in that they had good uh
performance and all of a sudden
Distortion would come in and then it
would vanish after a while uh turned out
this is a fault in implementing ESS tax
that the ESS has not documented and even
to this day they have not provided any
kind of app node or anything to their
implementers to warn them how they
should be implementing it to avoid this
problem and this is is indeed a very new
uh streamer that's excellent from fo the
r s but it has this IMD hump in it uh
just anyway es makes good tag chips but
they're just such a terrible company
when it comes to supporting their o with
uh good design so anyway this shows
again importance of of making
measurements uh I explained to this
community a community probably not
familiar with consumer DS how there's a
choice of different attack filters now
and I measured and show their effect
that some of them don't even filter and
then I showed an example of of this AV
receiver which is a mar processor and
how had selected this super slow filter
that hardly filters anything instead of
what it should be doing which is one of
these and didn't even give the user a
choice to select one uh turns out their
newest ones the av10 that just came out
um actually now has a second uh filter
that lets you do this after I blame them
and beat them up good in reviews I'm
glad to see them respond and actually
put a second filter in there for those
of us want correct
response um the uh other complaint
people were making is that even with
multi-one they said well you're only
testing at a few frequencies so uh this
test actually sweeps from 20 KZ down to
20 Hertz so it goes across all the
frequencies and to do that you have to
capture a wider band with 48 khz not
just uh uh 22 khz that I normally used
so when you do that you're capturing
things in the ultrasonic range and if
your filters aren't any good like I
showed earlier it has a side effect that
it has this Rising level in this test so
you can quickly see poor measurement
over here uh on this thing but even when
that's not happening we can see the
Distortion in this expensive AV
receivers is way up here way the heck
worse than our our this cheap reference
tck which was a $99 dck that came out a
few years ago which had the time we
thought was amazing it's still very good
but today we can do better so anyway uh
that's an issue with the filters I run
this test called the linearity in theory
every D should be able to nail this test
but they don't two enemies of this test
one is noise and and you can see that if
this graph goes up exponentially sort of
has a curve to it that's usually noise
interference and then if you have signal
processing errors many dacks don't have
any signal processing in them so they
don't usually screw up but there are
dacks like this one that use r2r
architecture this is a Shea iGo Dack
earlier generation than the current ones
and had an internal 20 bit uh ddaa
converter so if we feed a 24-bit data it
needs to properly dither that and
converted if you don't do that and just
do a straight conversion you get this
kind of error that increases so you know
we're talking a $2,500 deck and it has
problems like this uh by the way if I
were giving the presentation at a I
wouldn't have mention any of these
brands or model numbers their protocol
is to be polite and and not get specific
but for you guys you're getting that
bonus
information so this a interesting graph
that you haven't seen before I went
through all the Decks that I've tested
and uh separated them into separate
sections and then did a statistical
analysis of getting their means and and
uh standard deviation in them and uh
divided them into four categories
uh in there one I called just straight
consumer D majority of what I test then
uh that's about 330 um 22 of uh Dax are
tested actually part of audio interfaces
and uh and a couple of pro CD players
and what have you so that's that and
then uh we have a c AV receivers and AV
processors that's another bucket and
then the custom ones are DXs that
actually don't use a chip they implement
the digital to analog converion version
themselves so I said let's look at their
sign out performance and see how they do
the highest performance by far is
achieved by with these consumer decks
using standard off the-shelf chips with
excellent implementation they get up to
almost 125 de I think 123 and change is
the best they can get and then but the
downside is in consumer D World people
build really really poor stuff so much
so that Excel when he graphs this it
actually it says look these samples are
so far out I'm just going to show them
outside of the error bars in here and
throw them down here so you can see the
taags go down here down to sign out of
almost 35 DB um so the the uh deviation
is quite wide in consumer dexs and that
pulls their median down actually even
though you can get very high performance
dexs audio interfaces don't they best
case performances up here uh so lower
than a consumer but luckily they they're
afraid they pay a little bit more
attention to engineering and their worst
case is not that bad so their worst case
sign is only 95 DV compared to 35 36 for
Consumer devices AV devices have just
been bad this regardless the price we're
talking $20,000 processors even not
being able to match you know a consumer
deck as $100 uh that's starting to
change uh that Moran V10 that I just
tested is is quite good um so but this
is really there to try push that
industry forward say this you shouldn't
have performance like this when you
charge a lot more than this so this
needs to go up and then the other
interesting thing was this custom D
category and say the people say well I
can you know reinvent the wheel better
and um but turns out they can't reinvent
the wheel better uh the uh best case
performance is up here and I think
that's from um uh mola mola uh uh Dak
and cord deck I think are up here um but
their average is quite low and they syn
quite low uh and prices are way up there
because they're trying to do custom
implementation some of these things are
thousands and thousands of dollars so
clearly from Performance Point of View
there's no justification to build your
own deck just use the standard chip put
it in there implement it well and you
get support
performance uh this probably not news to
you all that read my forum and read my
reviews but I'm sure it was Major news
to the audio engineering Society in in
the makeup of uh if you look at the uh
uh all the Dax in excellent category in
my chart which is sign out grade than
110 and you look at the headquarters for
where that compan is from not where the
products manufactured uh prob if you
look at that more of them are made in
China but by far China dominates now
partially that's because those are the
companies send me products but also they
send me products because they know they
measure well so 110 of them are out
there and look at Japan gosh only one
product that's a Panasonic Blu-ray
player he the only one that made it in
in that domain uh 40 years
ago Japan would be here and China
wouldn't exist at this chart but what
reversal fortunes were such major names
in in in that world are not producing
products that that are you know have low
Distortion noise you know I can
get more Basics than that few products
from EU um um UK is not part of EU
anymore so I put their own category here
these are all cord products but there's
they're expensive but they perform well
uh some us companies this is actually
the most hopeful thing in here that
Western companies can not only design
but also manufacture in us and in some
cases keep up with what comes out of
China which is amazing but uh not that
many companies are trying I think many
more of them could do that but they're
choosing to sell on hype and and
marketing and so forth so I did another
the analysis which is can we correlate
price with the Dax Signet performance
and obviously we can correlation one
means that you know perfect the more you
pay the more performance you get and
this is basically zero you know it say
there's essentially no correlation uh
look at the expensive deck in here
here's a $14,000 Deck with a sign out of
and here we have sign out of 123 at less
than $1,000 good news for consumers is
that we have this incredible density
down here that lowcost STX Rule and you
get a ton of them in here so um so
please don't go waste money on these
things if you are going to waste money
at least buy one that performs well
there up here at least uh on this
thing and uh some of this I don't know
how useful this to you guys but I'll
mention them um these DXs actually their
noise performance is the top of the the
ones at the top of the sign are actually
have less noise than my analyzer so when
I measure the sign ad which is dominated
by noise it's uh I'm measuring the
analyzers much as I'm measuring demo
even more like two-thirds of noise may
be coming from analyzer one third of it
may be coming from a deck so I've asked
a your Precision is there another one
the card and they're like no nothing's
coming but there's a trick which is the
noise amplifier you can actually amplify
the noise let's say by factor of 10 and
then measure and then divide the
measurements by 10 to get the uh much
better uh performance numbers much more
accurate performance numbers and I think
AP should uh uh design something like
that integrated we need that we can't be
in a world where analyzers are worse
than the Dax um one are The Quirk of the
audio Precision in here and the
competitors actually do this right in
that audio Precision only supports a
interface to talk to a DEC and problem
with AIO interface is that many dacks
today use what is called USB class
compliant which means they you just plug
in the deck on Windows Mac and Linux and
it just works so they no longer provide
any drivers and don't provide AIO
drivers either some do topping does and
a few other companies do but most of
them don't so how do you test them with
the analyzer well there's a emulation Li
uh library or uh middleware called AIO
for all and you can fire that and it
will take any audio device that Windows
recognizes and convert that to um an U
interface and then audio Precision can
see it and that's how I test majority of
the taxs that I test uh but there's a
problem there's a class of um Dax and
the way they announce themselves to
Windows um is different and cause a bug
in a for all that causes it to actually
not send the bits as is but perform some
kind of conversion on them and you can
see this is actually a deack I
initially tested it through as you
forall and if you look in here you can
see all this spikes and you think boy
something is really seriously wrong with
this stack Well turns out if you use the
wasapp interface which is Windows native
interface so you don't use the emulation
but you use a uh bit exact uh interface
to it all of that vanishes but running
this measurement requires a hack and you
can't use all the features of audio
prision so my message here is really to
audio prision saying darnet support
wasapp exclusive don't rely on AIO AIO
is a interface that came from Steinberg
many many years ago it's proprietary
interface requires licensing and that's
why Windows doesn't support it natively
I don't think Mac does it either and so
it's time for uh Audi Precision to
support Wasabi to get around this
problem uh but interesting I see some
reviewers uh publishing measurements
with this problem in them and and uh you
know kind of naive they don't know what
they don't know and they go talk about
the performance of a dag where poor dag
is actually better performing than than
they think it is um this is a big
problem that I talk about in the U paper
a lot which is that we don't really have
standards for what the output voltage of
a Dax should be uh most of the Dax tests
have four Volts for XLR and two volts
for RC yeah but there's no standard that
forces them to do that there's no
compliance there's no nothing really I'm
the only one that highlights it that we
should have that so some DXs put out
less some DXs put out a lot more and
then that gets compounded with
amplifiers that you're going to hook up
to these DS these amps some of them have
they have widely varying gains there's
no standard there either the gain could
be 35 DV or it could be 12 DB and what
that means is the amount of voltage they
require from a deck to get to their
maximum power varies and it's all over
the place it's like wild west so and in
general they're working off of the uh
old assumptions of really low output
voltages from Dax and when they do that
they have to have more gain and more
amplification and that actually lowers
the performance of The Amplifier the
power amplifier so I like to see these
things a lot more standardized a lot
more specified it's not even clear what
the gain is in some amplifi and because
they won't spec it so anyway these are
all detailed uh in the paper if you have
more interest in there so bottom line
was that you can have incredible
performance at $100 and you can have
state-ofthe-art uh from $500 $900 this
number would have been lower a couple
years ago but as you know inflation is
really caught up to us on this thing and
we can get to what what I call provable
transparency in that anything less than
110 115 to 120 DB is inaudable at all in
all cases in all situations so you don't
even need to do double blind testing or
anything like that because it's
basically playing whatever the bits that
it is that you give it and we can get to
that point uh but if you have a device
that you know only has a sign out of 80
then you have to wonder whether it's
audable or not um uh unfortunately in
audio many companies are charging a lot
more and it's like inversely
proportional you can almost swear by
them the the more the more expensive
than that the lower the performance now
I'm generalizing but that's what
research shows and as I explained
earlier many of them can't even achieve
16 bit Fidelity yet they talk about
supporting higher res and you know how
great their
performances um they don't provide
measurements as I said and uh really
there's no way out of this thing you got
to measure to know uh you know I've
gotten the $20,000 DXs that poweron and
they have terrible problems and uh I
just test a great streamer from wiim uh
and it has excellent performance I just
did not expect them to produce that and
and uh just posted the review and so you
got to measure if you don't measure just
looking at the Box you can't tell
looking at just you know the marketing
Pages you can't tell so my message to a
yes AUD engineering Society was really
we as an industry we need to go and push
get back to objective performance get
companies to have a Clos Loop design
where you measure what you um uh
designed and you have a comparison with
other things I mean some companies just
measure and God knows what uh um
standards they have for what's
acceptable uh now they can go to the
library measurements I have so oh wait
wait a second there's this little $200
streamer from whim and has this
performance I shouldn't go to market
with considerably more noise and and
Distortion than them for no reason uh on
this thing okay uh since this was
supposed to be a 10-minute presentation
and uh we're into 32 minutes now I would
have gone through it much faster I'll
let them not that they can actually come
to this channel a s review and and and
learn more okay again I encourage you if
you have a few dollars to go get the
paper and by the way the reason I don't
have the paper for you to read is
because when you make submissions it
seemed like as owns your paper and so I
can't even give it away it's you sort of
give it to them and they hold the
copyright or something like it I don't
know if they'll come after me if I uh
put it out in public but I choose not to
ruffle their feathers so go pay that or
join the the AES I think it's only $300
to join it per year or for students even
cheaper so oh yeah it says the paper is
$33 price gone up um but anyway um I
encourage you to get the paper if you
want to read more otherwise my videos
are are pretty good anyway all right see
you in a future video bye-bye by